foreign
I can't be the only one who gets
triggered from listening to your shows
no everybody does I get triggered
sitting in here like every time somebody
calls in with a marriage question
infidelity question have you been
cheated on before yeah well of course
you see the correlation right
[Music]
what in the world is going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney show
talking about mental health and marriage
parenting schools whatever you got going
on in your world
some have called this the greatest
mental health and marriage podcast of
all time
nobody's called it that but we're just
gonna keep saying it oh hey on the show
here's what we do I we take real calls
from real people going through real
stuff and here's my promise I'm gonna
sit with you and we're gonna walk
through it together and we're gonna
figure out what your next step is
sometimes it's easy sometimes it's
really difficult and sometimes these
calls are funny and sometimes these
calls are really challenging I promise
is I'll tell you the truth and I'll try
to use an evidence-based
uh in insights to back up what I'm
saying it's just not some I try not to
be an idiot off the street just making
up stuff sometimes I do just because
that makes it funny but
um if you want to be on this show if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
and
let's go out to Philadelphia we were
born and raised and Kelly spent most of
her days on the playground let's talk to
Sarah what's up Sarah
hey how we doing what are you doing I'm
partying man what are you doing what the
heck I'm I'm incredibly honored to be on
your show well I am honored that you are
giving us your most precious resource
which is your time and you could be
doing so many other fun things this
morning
so you know I've been praying for you
for this moment
oh no
did we used to date or something I'm
that's my like biggest fear that an old
girlfriend's gonna call would be like
you were mean
no no not even close
you're like I would never date you all
right so what do you got
so I felt like I can't be the only one
who gets triggered from listening to
your shows no everybody does I get
triggered sitting in here
what do you get triggered about
seriously
like every time somebody calls in with
um
a marriage question infidelity question
I like project that onto my husband and
we get in a fight like I'm triggered
physically mentally everything
by these shows and
it started way back when you did your I
think it was your first marriage and
money show with Rachel yep Rachel my
good friend yeah yeah and I
person you should come y'all should
y'all should come
and you can be triggered for like 36
straight hours
[Laughter]
no kidding I probably would be but I was
like I don't like that guy have you been
cheated on before
yeah
oh well of course you see the
correlation right
I guess I do I just like I feel like I
should be over it like I should be okay
like it's my problem now
it is but I don't like to use should in
this situation okay let's use a
different word because should has it
just often makes our bodies go into
defense mechanisms really somewhat
unconsciously so when someone's like you
shoulda bam I instantly have to protect
and defend myself now instead of
actually get to the problem okay
um should is often a shutdown word
doesn't mean that there aren't tons of
things that we should do I should take
care of my kids I shouldn't cheat on my
wife all those things are true but when
I'm trying to get to the bottom of why
my body is responding in a certain way
that word's often not helpful so okay
think of it this way
um
and I want you to take full ownership
and responsibility and it sounds like
you're more than willing to do that
you're really trying to figure out why
can't you just listen to
this goofball podcast
without your body taken off on you right
so let me ask you this question
are you still in relationship with the
person who cheated on you
yes okay
so
what is your body getting out of the
response it's providing you when you
listen to this show
your body's trying to protect you from
what
yeah from being a fool okay so that's
one of two things either you have made
an identity
out of a person who was cheated on
that's become the way you see yourself
and when when somebody cheats on us two
things happen one we have that that
relational violation right this Core US
is broken and
we lose trust in ourselves
because we should have seen it we should
have known I should have said something
earlier when I had an inkling and we
didn't and we just lose trust in
ourselves and that's unmooring right
yeah so
that can be one the other is
your body recognizes very similar
patterns over the last year or two
30 years no no I'm saying your body is
picking up on this thing may be going on
again
yeah
and so do you think this has become an
identity for you it's just kind of the
way you see the world
or are you having to wrestle with at a
at a scary scary level because you
probably made some promises to yourself
the last time
is your body picking up ah there's some
similar patterns here I remember I
remember this story from last time
yeah that's a great question
um because I'm a six on the aces
okay and my husband's a six only Aces so
you've got two very highly highly tuned
Radars pinging off each other all the
time right
yeah always yeah
yeah so
um
the thing is it's like the red flags
were there right now
no not anymore like I I point blank ask
them this morning I said Dr John's gonna
ask me
if I trust you like 100 percent
and he you know without even
finishing the sentence he said yes you
can trust me 100 percent
he even prayed he prayed with me before
this meeting
um
so that is a very different question
than
have you cheated on me again
right
it's a very different question and it's
an evasive question that we often ask to
keep ourselves safe from the truth right
so let's pretend that your husband's
been perfect he screwed up
um
what was the nature of the infidelity by
the way
huge porn and lust and inappropriateness
with
um customers
okay
um how long ago
D-Day was three years ago and we've been
we were married 27 years when I found
out how long was it going on before that
probably 27 years if not more okay
and you in retrospect do you see where
you missed it or was this just a total
shell shock
um I feel like I didn't miss it I
was led to believe that I was crazy yeah
were you let me ask that's a probably a
better way were you roundly deceived
or did you choose to not know
um
probably chose to not know okay all
right
because because one of those there's a
there's a level of pathology so here's
for for everybody listening and for you
Sarah here's one here's what I'm getting
at
um
Affairs happen one night stands happen
go into a work conference and you meet
somebody and you all start laughing and
one thing leads to another that happens
or
texting back and forth with a workmate
that leads to this at least this that
happens okay
and I'm not saying it's right I'm not
saying it's good I'm saying it happens
and I've got empathy for that situation
I understand it
okay if that leads to
significant dishonesty gaslighting why
are you can't trust me this is your
fault you never trusted anybody you've
been doing this since we were dating
and it leads to these giant cover-ups
well now we have another layer as far as
I'm concerned
okay
um and that layer of not only did I
do something outside of my value system
but now I'm going to just intentionally
destroy somebody else to prop it up and
keep it going
those are two separate issues to me and
as far as I'm concerned I may be wrong
here and that's fine if I am one is
infinitely more nefarious than the other
sure okay
and the the the other option is there's
this going on your husband's a natural
flirt he's always clicking out of the
computer whenever you come home the he's
the the search history is always deleted
when you pick it up even over something
silly like just checking movie times or
something
and that nagging feeling inside like oh
he is always flirting with those
customers a lot right and you choose to
not ask
there's a participation there right it's
not that he's hiding anything it's just
all right I was gonna keep my head down
and we're just gonna keep doing this
thing and so it could be a mix of any of
all that all that to say is
when you listen to my show and we're
talking we're having
real couples going through real hard
things right now
and real individuals wrestling with
infidelity and with trust and with all
those things
your body's response tells me that you
haven't fully either grieved it you
haven't fully owned it
and that it is still a way that you are
viewing the world it's still the the
glasses that you wear
sure
yeah that makes sense
and then the two questions so that
leaves me with two questions for you one
why listen to the show like stop
listening stop listening it's like man
every time I touch that stove it burns
my hand or
keep listening to the show and choose to
enter into a really difficult season of
healing because I don't know that you're
there yet
yeah I don't think I am either so why
have you chosen to not enter into that
what what are you getting by hanging on
to this thing you know that safety that
feeling of safety
yeah
I just feel like I'm I'm waiting for the
other shoe to drop every day
what does your husband say when you tell
him that
he says he understands but
he's faithful like he gets it now like
he wasn't always empathetic
um
but he says I can trust him what have
you asked him to do to prove to
demonstrate trust not to just say it
what have you asked him to do what
behaviors are different now
I asked him to cherish me
um
he's not very good at that I've asked
him
what is cherish what what does cherish
you mean
to think about
rounds how does he demonstrate that to
you
to bring me something
okay you want to buy you stuff
yeah or I don't know just anything write
me a note something that makes me
believe that he was thinking about me
okay
and
be affectionate with you be
flirt with you the way he flirts with
customers
yeah
so it doesn't always happen I know it
doesn't I can hear it in your voice yeah
and what you haven't done
you haven't said
I want you to give up your cell phone
and get a flip phone
what you haven't said is I'm gonna start
seeing customers not you I don't know if
y'all are at a family business I'm
making something up
I want you to consider another line of
work
because when you go off to see clients I
still can't breathe
right what you've asked him to do is
something on the periphery and I'm going
to say this with all due respect and
kindness and love to him and to you
I'll buy you stuff that's fine and I
will hold your hand when we're watching
TV
that has nothing to do with my
extracurricular affairs
hmm
and so what you're asking him to do or
two to and what your body's demanding
are two different things
gotcha you're asking to be cherished
like
the object of his
um
pornography you're asking to be you're
asking to for him to replace flirting
with customers and being inappropriate
with customers and pornography with you
right and that's not the issue my it my
guess is
he doesn't feel alive in his own home
and he's going looking for it
and that is a that is a relational
fracture that y'all gotta deal with I'm
not blaming you for that at all what I'm
saying is
his heart starts beating a little bit
faster when he's on the computer his
heart starts being a lot faster when
he's flirting with somebody that's not
you
right and his heart slows down and goes
when he walks in his own front door
right and that's a choice he's made for
30 freaking years
right and then y'all have done that
dance together see what I'm saying
yeah
and so it doesn't surprise me at all
that you hear or see these relationship
challenges that your body is like this
is it this is it right here in our house
there it is and yeah
you're it just starts going on and on
and on right the Alarm Systems sound
the truth
I don't know that y'all have done the
work after what happened
can I okay I'll just cut to it I think
you think other things happened
and you haven't full you still don't
believe him is what I think
and you all have moved on down the road
and he's just trying to get quote
unquote back to the way things were and
you haven't fully let him know that
there will never be a going back
that what y'all had for 30 years is over
now and if y'all are going to do
anything you got to build something new
going forward you haven't told him that
and you still think he hasn't told you
everything about what happened and you
haven't given him a path for regaining
trust in your home so if nothing did
happen
he doesn't have a way to show you that
he just has to keep saying it over and
over again and he's told you things for
30 years
right
so you see there's where there's just it
just gets in a figure eight Loop over
and over and over
yes and then eventually he's going to
get tired of coming home
and expecting you to read his mind
mm-hmm
I'm sorry expecting him to read your
mind
right and right
then somebody's gonna make him laugh and
now we're off to the races again
all right Buddy's gonna send him a funny
email that's not so funny that's
he's gonna be down a rabbit hole again
this isn't your fault I don't want you
to hear me say that in any shape form or
fashion he's got a ton of work to do and
and man I wish he'd call into the show
because I would tell him he needs to be
shut his mouth and start acting
differently and he's not doing that
right
but I think you all got to get to the
core healing here because you just
aren't there yet that's that's what I
think I could be out to lunch but that's
what it sounds like to me
no I think you hit the nail on the head
I'm sorry I wish I was wrong I wish I
was wrong
no it's good it's all good this is a
Divine appointment I was praying for
um
I wish that I wish the Divine could have
been kinder to to both of us
so here's the path forward
you have to own reality you have to
choose reality and I don't think you're
there yet
and so
often when folks get stuck and they are
in this Loop like you all are in
and I say this over and over and over on
this show I think it starts with a
letter
that you end up reading to him
and in the letter you got to be honest
if you still don't trust him if you
think he had an affair wasn't just
contained in pornography or in being
inappropriate as you said
if you think he did other things
you have to ask Point Blank
write that in the letter I still am
unable to trust you my body is still
telling me you're not safe
you have to give him a road map that of
your choosing
back to not back to to a new level of
trust somewhere
what would that look like what does he
need to do to earn that trust and then
he as a grown-up gets to make a choice
I'm not doing that I'm out or I'll do
anything in the world
to show you that I'm working on I'm
changing it could be marriage counseling
it could be getting rid of the phones it
could be no more computer access
whatever the things how crazy is is you
is you want to get it's up to you
and then you all have to decide
how do we recreate life inside this
house
what do I need to do to help you feel
alive and what does he need to do to
help you feel alive you've told him I
want you to cherish me want you to buy
me gifts I want you to think about me
he needs to be able to say I need you
this and I need this and I need this and
then you all spend the next 60 90 120
days two three four months
practicing meeting each other's needs
and meeting each other's needs all with
a goal of re-earning this trust back
building something completely new
start from a platform of reality honesty
truth
that's where we got to start Sarah
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of own your past change change your
future
um you can go through it and man you can
go through it with you and
um that can be something that unifies
you two together that you all use Joel
begin to build something new give me a
call back I'll walk with you every step
of the way we'll be right back
[Music]
hey John deloney here I say it all the
time you can't wish your way to a better
life it boils down to being intentional
about what you do every day intentional
acts become healthy habits and one of
the most important things you can do to
improve your mental and physical health
right now starting tonight is to get
enough quality sleep and I know this
from personal experience and for me
great sleep starts with an incredible
mattress and that's why I love dream
Cloud mattresses whether you're a back
sleeper a stomach sleeper or a side
sleeper because your dumb dog is always
in the way dream Cloud's combo of gel
memory foam and coil technology keeps
you cool and comfortable all night long
and right now dream cloud is running
their biggest offer ever 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings exclusively for my
listeners visit dreamcloudsleep.com and
enter your promo code John deloney
that's dreamcloudsleep.com and promo
code John deloney
all right we are back and it's time for
facts are your friends
there we go
all right today we are talking murder
podcast
Kelly's favorite
our true crime murder podcast all these
shows
is it psychologically healthy that's
what we're talking about today and I'm
going to tell you right now I'm gonna
make everybody mad so as the great T
Swift says Shake It Off already so here
we go
we have a culture that is obsessed
obsessed with True Crime
particularly women
Kelly is smiling
as though
I'm speaking directly into her soul
correct
I feel very seen right now let's just go
with that now we've always had true
crime stories told orally about Gods and
Monsters and quote unquote others right
true crime stories and storytelling in
general has been wired into us we are
storytelling and story making beings
it's how humans communicate have always
communicated we tell stories story is
how we make sense of the world and it's
how we participate in the world it's how
we experience things
without actually sleeping with the
neighbor without actually dying without
actually being in a car wreck without
actually whatever
is through story
somebody tells us a story this thing
happened we watch a movie we get to see
it happen but we don't have to actually
experience the full weight of that
tragedy or that ah but we get to kind of
participate when he hits the winning
home run or when Rocky comes back in
Rocky IV and and wins or whatever
we get to we get to be a bystander this
is how we are wired
and then modern media hits the scene and
we are captivated by serial killers
murder
Freddy Krueger Alfred Hitchcock all this
all the stuff right and it Taps into a
very natural very wired into us
um survival Instinct which is to always
be looking for threats
to identify threats to see them to be
able to predict ahead of time what they
might do what you might do this is what
makes humans humans this is the frontal
lobe right this is being able to say
okay if x happens and Y happens then I'm
gonna do Z right
so it kept us alive because we couldn't
fight bears but we could anticipate
bears
we could strategize about bears
and then in recent years with the
proliferation of True Crime shows Alfred
Hitchcock Twilight Zone War of the
Worlds and then Ted Bundy and then NYPD
Blue CSI NCIS signs of the Lambs cops
Law and Order the line between True
Crime fiction the unknown the dark
Forces and your neighbor who looks nice
but might actually be luring old people
over to eat them and skin them alive and
use their skin as a dress
it all is getting blurred together
and fantasy and fiction and reality in
your neighbors and your co-workers it's
all turning into the same river right
all these different creeks and
tributaries are dumping into the same
river and then podcast hits the scene
and the internet opens up a never-before
trove of interviews inside police files
interviews with detectives my dad my dad
got flown my dad's a homicide detective
for years and was a SWAT hostage
negotiator Nancy Grace flew my old man
to New York and to do a cold case and
when Nancy Grace's producers called my
dad like Hey do you remember this crime
he goes yeah that one still haunts me
they flew him to New York and he was on
the show right it was awesome
True Crime has become braided together
with celebrity culture and our ability
to to participate in a ringside seat to
what happened so think about when Ted
Bundy was on the scene there would be a
news article at six and then to get it
nine and then a newspaper
well now suddenly there's troves of Ted
Bundy movies Ted Bundy interviews Ted
Bundy poetry we can read it all we can
look at his pictures we can read all the
the transcripts of the
conversations you had with police police
officers we got it all right
and it's the ultimate rubber necking and
it's messing with us in ways we have not
fully metabolized yet so make no mistake
I will go to the mat with any
neuroscientist on the planet any social
scientist on the planet the media you
consume affects you it affects the way
you see the world the way you experience
the world and the way your body reacts
to the world
it's a great book by Dawn Cecil it's
called fear Justice and modern True
Crime and
Dawn writes by connecting facts from The
Real World with a fictional style
narrative format true crime stories
naturally blur the line between news and
entertainment
the melding of facts entertainment is
commonly referred to as infotainment if
you're a true crime junkie or a modern a
murder podcast junkie like I don't know
Kelly and Jenna
and their friends
you are being entertained by the death
murder investigation of something that
really happened packaged in an
entertaining way
that's crazy
and I think Kelly tell me if I'm wrong I
think the first podcast it was cereal
was that the first one that kind of set
all this off uh yeah probably so that
was the big one that um kind of kicked
off the podcast so I met Sarah Koenig
and like going down like that felt and I
haven't kept up with it in all the the
other Seasons but I remember her she
came and met with my law students and
was was a did a great presentation but
it sounded very altruistic like she got
she got
um had a question and kept asking and
kept asking very journalistic Endeavor
oh I think so yeah now there was other
podcasts I believe before that that were
kind of one-offs but hers was the first
one where you're telling a story in a
10-week Arc or whatever but um yeah her
started off with the story that she had
heard about this guy and it was like I
don't think he's guilty
and then it just goes from there
but it's it's the music swells and then
the wait till next week it like uses the
best parts of Alfred Hitchcock in the
best parts of like friends and then a
real murder and it braids it all
together and we're like and what happens
and then there's that little bit of
could this happen in my town right in
this in my neighborhood Maybe
allegedly right that's my favorite
allegedly
um and so and then I remember being so
bummed out by S town do you remember
that one
yeah that was uh one County over from
where my husband's from so that I
explained so much yes it does where you
went man hunting
um
but but listen here here's what's so
frustrating about that
I I waited through that entire podcast
and I got to the end and they explained
it and it could have been a 16 minute
this guy was doing this particular thing
I think it was smelting or whatever he
was doing and it affected his brain
chemistry right and he was mad yeah
but they that's not how they told it
they kept me hooked for I'll say one
with that one I kept waiting for like
there was going to be this big thing and
yeah there really wasn't oh man okay so
why do we consume this madness why do we
do this
some experts say
we consume these shows as a way of
quote-unquote learning or mentally
rehearsing what we would do so it's
about preparation it's a dress rehearsal
so we watch Silence of the Lambs or we
watch even and I know this is a true
crime but for a lot of adolescent males
it kind of is like the John Wick movies
okay so this is what I would do I'm
gonna bury all these rad Weapons Under
my concrete floor and then chip it out
with a sledgehammer and then ride a
horse with a sword down the subway it
all gets mushed together here or like if
Hannibal Lecter comes to my house ah
okay I'm gonna number one you're not
gonna do anything but so it's about
preparation it's a dress rehearsal
number two we consume these shows as I
said earlier as a way of participating
pretending to get inside the head of a
murderer or a detective or a victim's
family without getting blood on our
hands it's the ultimate voyeuristic
um activity when we and it's consumed in
a podcast it can be super powerful
because get this your brain creates the
art the actual pictures in your mind
from the words of the show The cognitive
work that goes into the imagination can
be very very powerful because your brain
draws from what it already knows
and so when it says things like and the
neighbor had a Shifty look about him
your brain will go looking for your
neighbors
it's different than a movie because in a
movie you see Robert England playing
Freddy Krueger and it's like oh that I
got a picture of Freddy Krueger
not so with a podcast with a podcast
your brain has to carry the cognitive
load of the story it inserts people from
your past remember that coach yeah coach
was a little bit sketchy he might eat
children and it begins to craft this
narrative around people you know and I'm
looking at Kelly and she's like oh I
feel exposed
a little bit on that one but not totally
because I don't you do I don't see
people like in my world where I start
thinking about that that's okay but you
don't think about it but does your body
and I realized I said that in the kind
of the creepiest way possible thanks
John Mayer
um your body I said that's so gross
um I don't know now Jenna says that she
does the um
like how I would how I would handle
myself in this situation and I don't do
that but she says she does yeah I think
I more so started listening to them when
I moved to Nashville from my home
because I was like okay I am a 18 year
old woman moving to a new city and one
I'm intrigued by like the cycle like why
do they do that like what makes them
want to do that but also okay what can I
learn from these stories of like okay
here's what not to do as a young woman
living on her own in a new city so you
listen to these as like research kind of
I mean like I know I'm never gonna wear
my hair in a ponytail when I go to the
grocery store because they'll grab me
from the back never you'll never catch
me doing that
oh yeah things like that
incredible
all right so
this hey this is the reason why
um
in education why we ask kids to figure
things out because it develops new
cognitive Maps instead of just
presenting it to them in a picture our
form
all right so number three some experts
put out there
that people listen to murder podcast
obsessively because they need to see
good triumph over evil um with all the
Mayhem and madness out in the world it
lets us believe a little bit of God
overcomes
except I'll say this every podcast I've
ever listened to
good never wins
there's it never ends well yeah I don't
see I mean
I don't buy that argument but no I don't
because I know that even when I listen
to
different podcasts I have to to take a
break from them I have to detox because
your brain gets kind of too into that
and there's all of a sudden you can't
find good because even if yes they catch
the person there's still somebody
murdered there's still probably multiple
people and there's still this
you know what is wrong with our brains
what's wrong with people so no I don't
buy that as an argument
all right so here's what we need to sit
on
Cecil says that consumers of True Crime
are being exposed to a distorted picture
of criminal behavior and justice
so in a true crime I've walked into
homes where there are
unfortunately people have passed away
who have been who have died violent
deaths
there is no music swelling there's no
um like loud piano and Symphony that
that comes there's no ticking clocks or
dramatic pauses
it's this weight in the silence that I
can't explain unless you've been in
there I've been an active shooter
exercises I've been in a building with
an active shooter on the campus
it is not like it is on a TV show it's
very very different there's a level of
Haunting that is unique and it is
weighty in a way that I can only explain
if you've been there it's why police
officers often hang out with other
police officers because there's a shared
weight that they just carry because they
know it goes on in the in the homes in
their neighborhood in the middle of the
night that regular neighbors don't know
and so when you consume podcast as
infotainment when you consume murder and
investigations and police work and bad
guys and good guys as infotainment it
distorts reality in a pretty profound
way
it also decreases confidence in the
criminal justice system as a whole when
all you consume is
a 10-part series and you go into the
next 10 part series and you go to the
next 10 part series
and you look over the course of a year
and you've consumed 10 10 part series
you've consumed 10 trials that may have
happened over the last 50 years totally
botched totally screwed up somebody like
a police officer with a Vengeance a bad
cop whatever
it's really easy to let those things
shift your bell curve and suddenly you
lose faith in everything the bad guy
always gets away there's murderers
around every corner eating kids and and
you know murdering dogs or whatever
you say something know anybody that's
eating kids I know I'm trying to be
dramatic another thing um I have a
cousin who is a prosecutor has been for
years and she's talked about how
the rise of True Crime has made their
jobs harder because people expect that
there's we always called it the magic
printer when we used to watch it yeah
the mass spectrometer and you know and
they think they know all these things
now and like well that's not real life
so juries think that they're more
educated and they're not and it's making
their jobs prosecutors jobs harder
because they don't have the evidence
that you see on TV and in movies and
those kind of things half most of it
because it's not real yeah those that
technology doesn't yeah they think you
just put it in the computer and out you
know yeah and it and so it has
definitely affected that because people
think they know more yes and they know
just enough to be stupid and they know
enough
Hollywood to then look over at the
police officers and say you all must be
incompetent idiots or the prosecuting
attorneys you should have done this what
about this right right
so I am Holy with all of my guts not
compelled by the literature that
suggests there is no correlation between
violent media and increases in all cause
violence
I also am going to expand violence so if
you tell me kids can play active shooter
video games for 20 years and there's no
increase in
gun violence cool
I don't believe that all cause violence
meaning a body that is always heightened
a body that is anxious a body that is
depressed a body that is a little bit
sharper a little bit louder a little bit
more anti-social a little bit more
isolated I I don't buy that not even for
a second
um I'm wholly unconvinced by data that
suggests there is no psychological toll
or cost to mainlining this type of
entertainment I just don't buy it
um it might not make more violent kids
but it might make them as I said more
anxious more depressed more ADHD more
prone to iceling behavior practicing of
suicidal behavior these correlative
studies saying there are no problems are
in my opinion they are highly misleading
I just don't buy them consuming and
participating in violence is going to
have an effect on the way you experience
the world
period
period and listen we know from other
other academic disciplines the
importance and strength of Behavioral
models a picture of new Behavior Alters
our Behavior it gives our brains a new
map to follow
it's why initiatives to increase
diversity reputation and media is so
important it changes our feelings and
emotions and thoughts it gives us a new
model oh somebody who looks like that
could be an attorney I've never seen
that before that's why those initiatives
are so important
but those same media companies didn't
come out and say hey all the violence
that we put out here that doesn't impact
Behavior at all and these media
companies talk out of both sides of
their mouth we need to provide new
pictures so that we can give new People
Avenues for empathy for Behavior change
and ah that doesn't alter anything
it's not intellectually honest
and we know that when we watch the news
over and over and over again it makes us
more anxious more depressed more Angry
more rageful why in the world would we
think it doesn't apply to us so here's
my three insights and
Kelly you get the final rebuttal here we
go
there is a shifting of the bell curve
that happens
most people don't personally know
someone who's been kidnapped beheaded
and murdered or whatever happens in
these podcasts now we have murder
podcasts and horror movies and we know
so much more I'm personally convinced
after years of hanging out with police
officers veterans and First Responders
that it shifts our bell curve into
things that never happened would even
enter our mind to things that happen all
the time everywhere
and the data just doesn't bear that out
it makes our bodies more alert more of
the time podcasts this is number two
podcasts are a new technology that
affects us more than we know
we are over informed and under
experienced we have seen a million sex
acts on TV
that's probably a little bit uh that's
probably a lot but we've seen a lot
yet the data tells me that fewer and
fewer people are having intimacy in real
life
we see so many violent acts on TV
yet we have more and more parents who
don't let their kids go to their
grandparents funerals because they don't
want to bother them they don't scare
them
and so we've got kids who have seen
countless murders and deaths on TV but
they've never been in a room and felt
the weight
of somebody in a casket over there and
The Grieving that's going on
collectively they've seen a lot of
sexual activity on TV and they've never
wasted an entire movie reaching over
trying to hold somebody's hand
so there's a disconnect between what I'm
seeing and what I've my body's
experiencing and when it comes to
podcasts here's why this is so different
for all of us
historically speaking to be in a room
with Joe Rogan and listen to Joe talk to
his three best friends about really deep
and Meandering topics
for all of human history to be privy to
that conversation you had to be in that
room
so we have bodies that have evolved over
time to gather information in a
multitude of ways sound smell sight
touch eye crinkles head movement
shoulders up shoulders down all that
stuff is data for us we're having
interactions and conversations
and now I can just put in my headphones
and head on down the street or get on my
Mower and mow my yard or whatever and
I'm getting all of that insight into my
mind but I'm not there
that is changing the way our bodies
interacts with the information that we
get it's all new is it necessarily bad
no I'm not going to say that at all
that's one of the things we try to do on
this show we try to let you pull up a
seat to a table with me and somebody
who's struggling that's that's the
purpose of the show
but it's affecting us
it's affecting how our bodies Express
empathy it's affecting how our bodies
experience fear it's a it's affecting us
in ways that we don't know yet
three and this is something that my dad
told me I'll never forget this I was all
into horror movies as a kid up until my
my late 20s I saw every movie that came
out I love scary movies I liked
interesting scary movies I liked the way
they the cinematography the way scared
people I like bad guys in those movies I
watched everything
and I'll never forget my dad walked
through one day my dad the homicide
detective and I was watching some
horror movie on TV and he just quietly
said something which is which was not
like him he quietly said
I just can't ever imagine thinking this
is entertainment and he just walked on I
remember being like ooh dad dropping the
truth bombs on your little
and then I started going into these
homes myself
and so I'll just say this the death and
torture and murder of someone the
complete destruction of a family
I I can't wrap my head around consuming
that for entertainment
um
and that's just me and so I know those
stories exist I know that there are
people working through them and from the
journalistic Endeavor like what you know
Koenig did Sarah did with cereal there
are journalistic stories that need to be
told about Injustice about things that
are going unseen things happening in
marginalized communities all that's
important
it's tough for me to consume it as
entertainment
I'll pass it on to Kelly for the final
word
be so funny if you're just like go to
hell John now all I'm gonna say is for
those that can't see right now if those
are listening on podcasts John is
wearing a shirt that says The Killers
that's all I have
and with that we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hollow.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to
Jennifer in D-Town in Dallas Texas
what's up Jennifer
hi Dr John how are you I'm good how are
you
pretty good I'm
actually getting to speak
because I'm talking to you
podcast Junkie
no definitely not I can't handle it good
for you good for you
it's a healthy brain you got there all
right so what's up
well my question for you is how can I be
a less controlling significant other so
I just had
uh
seventh month relationship end because I
kind of suffocated the guy
and I'd
like to
work on that part of myself so
I kind of want to know where that comes
from and
yeah I kind of hate that part of myself
so I'd like to figure out how I can work
on it and understand it well I don't
want you to hate any part of yourself
can we start there
sure okay
um something about a relationship
set your body on guard
and really makes your body worried about
somebody abandoning you
or somebody hurting you
and just trying to solve that by really
tightening up your grip
and so I just want to honor the fact
that your body's trying to take care of
you in the best way it knows how and
ah you've learned that it it chokes
people unconscious and so we're just
going to learn a different different set
of tools
but I don't want you to start from a
place of hate is that cool
cool or as my friend Ian simkin says
um
whatever you think your hate is doing
Love Can Do Better
okay so let's start from that place is
that fair
okay what makes you think you smothered
this guy
[Laughter]
okay so this is a spoiler alert and if
I'm the first person first person ever
tell you this I am so sorry
but sometimes guys make up bull crap to
get out of relationships
um yeah a lot of people who love me in
my life have told me that that's
bullcrap but
um I regardless I do still have those
kind of controlling feelings and I would
still like to deal with them in a more
healthy way okay teach me about your
controlling feelings tell me about them
um
well mainly the idea of him just going
off and having fun maybe a guy's weekend
or anything without me
I just kind of have a fear of missing
out
like I
I don't like I want to be a part of that
um
let me think
um let's take him off the table when
have you done this before
oh and every other romantic relationship
I've done this okay give me an example
um
this relationship that just ended he was
gonna go away on a ski trip with his dad
for like two weeks and
um I just couldn't mentally wrap my
brain around the idea that he didn't
want to spend those two weeks with me
like why can't I come why don't you want
to have that fun with me because
the person I'm dating kind of becomes my
whole world and I I would not ever go on
a trip without him because he's my
favorite thing and I would rather stay
in town to spend time with him or take
him with me on a trip and I just can't
even fathom
wanting a two-week break from a person
and the way you're framing this is so
instructive
so relationships for you are not for
connectivity relationship for you is a
drug
who left you
um
when I was somebody somebody hurt you
bad who did it
well how much time do you have doctor no
I was not hurt that bad um as a teenager
um my mom left and
um she kind of just didn't reach out for
months I I would call and she would
answer I think she's pretty like ashamed
of just breaking up our family Jennifer
Jennifer
that's really bad
don't ever minimize that again
okay
how old were you
like 17.
and my guess is when somebody does that
they've usually left that relationship
years before they actually walk out the
door
is that fair
yeah did your mom struggle with
addiction
um no
why'd you leave
um she was just really unhappy with
their marriage I think she was more
trying to prove a point she wanted my
dad to fight for her to care to show
show her
interests she wanted I think she wanted
his attention and he just
took the other Road and said you're
being ridiculous get back over here and
they 100 just let it fall apart
did you have to fight for attention as a
kid to get your mom to notice you
um
yeah yeah I think so yeah what about Dad
um dad's love was I guess what you would
call merit-based conditional as long as
yeah as long as I was doing something
accomplishing something and I will say
after my mom left my dad he had to get a
second job and then he started dating
and he disappeared too and then the same
thing with my older siblings
um she kind of leaned on all her friends
and I was just kind of Forgotten
I mean you just laid it out
yeah but how do I fix this
um so let's let's run through that map
real quick so you grow up and you have a
picture
that love is Mom starts a fire and Dad's
job is to put it out that's how that's
how she receives love
mm-hmm
she causes a scene and he has to come
rescue her and if he doesn't rescue her
he doesn't love her
I can imagine a scenario where Dad gets
really tired of that over the years
right and he begins to create an ALT
universe that you probably will never
fully understand because they're
probably not going to ever tell you the
full picture maybe they will but who
knows
so you have this picture
of
you bet if you if you don't come get me
you don't love me
and love for you was a tool
right
it was the key to Dad it was the key to
Mom
and then all of a sudden
they vanished
and like a kid who was
thrown off the back of a boat and a
stick comes by that kid is going to
cling to that stick as tight as they can
yeah until it snaps
okay so every time you enter into a
romantic relationship Jennifer it's not
it's not about connectivity it's not
about peace it's about oxygen
yeah 100 yeah
the only way I know through this there's
two two paths to take oh actually
there's one path with two action steps
on it action step number one is you have
to commit to loving you enough to go see
a counselor to work through a lifetime
of trauma
yeah
um I actually
am on my third week with somebody from
better help so yeah I'm so excited about
it I'm so excited about it good I'm I'm
really proud of you because that's hard
because saying something out loud got
you hit when you were a kid you don't
have to answer that
and
you're going to have to practice
feeling overwhelmed
and not making relationships some zero
because when you enter into a
relationship it becomes you versus
everybody else in the in the person who
loves life
you versus their dad you versus their
mom you versus their old friends you
versus everybody their boss
that's just not fair
to you or them right and so you're gonna
have to practice when your boyfriend
that you care about you've been with
seven months says hey I'm gonna go spend
a week with my dad
you're gonna have to practice feeling
that wash over your body
oh
and then going and doing the next right
thing which is saying that is so amazing
that you and your dad still want to
spend time together I'm super jealous of
that that's awesome
and then you go home and you feel left
out you feel alone I want you to sit in
that call somebody write that stuff down
because you know that's not true
your feelings aren't telling you the
truth because what your feelings are
telling you is that guy's leaving you
he's picking Dad over you he's always
going to leave and your body screams
don't let him go
that's a lie it's not true
you just gonna hang out his old man
which by the way if he is the kind of
relationship he wants to go spend two
weeks with his dad he'll make a great
husband
right
right you're gonna have to choose to
enter into the fire for a season until
your body recognizes oh oh
they left
mom left
dad bailed
but that doesn't mean he will
and I can feel you not breathing very
much tell me what you're feeling
um
I mean I figured that I'm gonna have to
just muscle through that feeling no no
no no no
no Jennifer not mustard
opposite
oh you're not swimming Upstream you are
a leaf going Downstream
okay okay when you feel it you're
muscling through it that is that grip
in fact I want you to practice this
consciously when you feel that you're
dating somebody new and they're like hey
I gotta I just got a call I gotta work
late tonight and instantly your body's
like you're choosing work over me
I want you to look down and consciously
open your hands up
uh open them up
we are not muscling through anything the
opposite we are letting go
okay
you don't like that do you
no um I like it it's okay if you hate it
Jennifer it's okay if you hate it no I
don't I don't hate it I'm just grateful
for a new thing to try because I mean
this feeling makes me so miserable so I
I don't hate it I'm I'm excited to try
will you write Jennifer a letter
17 year old Jennifer
okay and I want you to start it off
with this line
17 year old Jennifer
I love you
and mom left because something was going
on with her not with you
okay
then I want you to tell Jennifer how
beautiful she was
and how sorry you are that Dad
weaponized love
and that Mom weaponized love
and commit to her as older Jennifer
that you are going to redefine love for
your body
so that relationships are not something
that you are not a drug the
relationship's not dope relationships
not oxygen relationship is peace
okay
you don't like that at all
um
no I I don't dislike it
I mean I'll try why are you crying
um
I don't know just
I don't know it's just a lot of emotions
there with talking about it I guess yeah
I'm gonna tell you something crazy
there's nothing wrong with you
thank you I'm not saying that like in
some like stitching on a pillow kind of
way you're not broken you're not
dysfunctional
your body's just trying to keep you safe
and the two people the two freaking
people
who are never supposed to leave
now they bailed on you
yeah the two people who are supposed to
look at their little bitty girl and say
you can burn down
the tallest building in the world and
you're still my little girl
they didn't do that they said hey if you
uh run real fast
[Music]
I'll buy you pancakes
if you uh get such and such a grade also
I'll wink at you
they weaponize the whole thing man
it's gonna take some time to practice a
new basketball shot and your basketball
shot is
not feeling like everybody's decisions
are anti-jennifer because they're not
when you love somebody and you care
about them or you're dating them you
like them a lot
and
we're gonna practice wanting the best
for him we're gonna practice them having
great relationships and them having
laughter in them having Joy we're going
to practice those things
because that makes them better able to
love me
to love you
to meet your needs
stay staying counseling okay and at some
point you may need to transition from
better help to an in-person therapist
which is great
you've got a long history
two important things Jennifer never
again say it's not that bad what you
experienced is hell
I'm sorry
[Music]
sorry
second thing is you're worth being well
and you're worth the fight
my promise to you is there's peace on
the other side of this
don't stop searching for peace we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as you wrap up today's show
Kelly went and got meta on all of us
the song's about killing
by The Killers
in case you're wondering ladies and
gentlemen she was in honors classes
that Kelly actually I was
[Laughter]
actually I was
hmm
that's actually where she got her first
tattoo gun and then it all just
fell apart after that song's called
Jenny was a friend of mine
by The Killers it was like this
we took a walk that night but it wasn't
the same we had a fight on the Promenade
Promenade
Promenade yeah Hooked on Phonics worked
for me out in the rain
she said she loved me but she had
somewhere to go she couldn't scream
while I held her close I swore I'd never
let her go
tell me what you want to know come on
there ain't no motive for this crime
Jenny was a friend of mine
gosh dude I did not know this is what
this song was about
I know my rights I've been here all day
and it's time for me to go so let me
know if it's all right I just can't take
this I swear I told you the truth she
couldn't scream while I held her clothes
I swore I'd never let her go
Jenny was a friend of mine man ruined
that song for me Kelly geez I thought
that was about two friends who fall in
love it's
it is not
mind blown see you guys soon love y'all